olá so Karolina hello I'm Carolina and I
come from Chile I'm an exchange student
in Berlin after half a year here I want
to see the island of loserdom and the
Baltic Sea right now I'm in the seaside
resort of herring stores come with me
it's so pretty the streets look lovely
I'd never have imagined these buildings
would have so many decorative details
look at the colors for instance the
windows the marble columns the balconies
Gorney it's really impressive how
beautiful this town is look how
beautiful this hotel is I really sense
the atmosphere of the aristocrats who
used to stay here and now I'm enjoying
what they've left to us thank you
you know what I've already heard lots
about the famous piers of loserdom
they're special because they reach far
out into the sea
how pretty the birds look over there
I'll take a picture to record it the
sand is just like in Chile just as
pretty gorgeous it's a long time since
I've been on a beach I got the waters
much clearer than in Chile there are no
algae here here you can go swimming
without worrying about it a trampoline
on the beach when did I last go
trampolining shall we what fun it
reminds me of when I was small and
jumped around with my sister
Malaka gong-gong look what I found on
the beach reducer dome yon a wicker
chair either to protect you from the Sun
we don't have these in Chile just beach
umbrellas let's go and find out how
these chairs are made
it is where they're made very
interesting kind of may I try I mean
inter huh I thought okay I'd fallen ten
decency okay in 2010 solution see thank
you love because the material is stiff
in my bizarre
yoga I think it would take me forever to
make one of these chairs but I'm getting
better with time after this long day on
loserdom I'm going to leave you now and
relax in this marvelous chair I hope
you've enjoyed getting to know the
island as much as I have